Did you know the hardest part of our body
isn’t our bones, but the enamel that covers
our teeth?
And now scientists are on the cusp of figuring
out where this enamel came from!
Hint: it once lurked in the briny deep during
the Silurian period!
Hello!
It’s Natalia Reagan for DNews and I’m
ready to take a bite a out of some science.
Teeth- they are amazing!
They can tell us so much about someone’s
diet, background, overall health, their hygiene
(or lack thereof)!
Heck!
Teeth aren’t just for eating- We can even
tell if our ancestors used their teeth to
make tools- how great is that!
But human teeth also contain the hardest mineral
in the body- enamel!
And nearly all tetrapods- or 4 limbed land
dwelling animals- have enamel on their teeth,
too.
But what exactly IS enamel?
Tooth enamel is the hardest tissue in the
human body and it's comprised mostly of a
mineral fittingly called hydroxyapatite, which
is crystalline calcium phosphate.
This is the part of the tooth that dentists
are most concerned with preserving since it
protects it from cavities and other dental
maladies.
Even though it’s the top layer of the tooth,
it’s not responsible for the tooth’s color
as it’s transparent.
But how did enamel get there in the first
place?!
Well, scientists have found that an ancient
fish might hold clues to how enamel came to
cover our chompers.
This fierce wee minipredator called Psarolepis
romeri cruised the seas 410 to 415 million
years ago.
Scientists dissected the fossilized skull
of this minipredator and found that parts
of their scales and skull were comprised of
an enamel-like substance called ganoine.
Their teeth, on the other hand, did not have
the enamel-like ganoine and were comprised
of naked dentine.
Similarly, some living fish do not have enamel
on their teeth but some recognizable fish
like piranhas, grunts, and those ravenous
cartilaginous fish like this guy (point to
shirt) do!
Yes, shark teeth are also made with a hard
mineral called fluoroapatite or fluorinated
calcium phosphate which is very similar to
hydroxyapatite, except with the added protection
of fluoride.
That’s why sharks don’t get cavities!
So, how did enamel GET to our teeth from the
scales of ancient fish?
Time to get to the root of the problem!
Some scientists have surmised that the armored
scales on ancient fish evolved to become teeth.
And if those scales had enamel on them, that
would explain how enamel made it’s way on
our teeth.
But, upon further analysis of Psarolepis romeri’s
fossilized skull and scales, it was clear
that the distribution of ganoine was not a
uniformed layer; the enamel was scattered.
So perhaps the scales didn’t re-situate
themselves to become enamel covered teeth,
but maybe the enamel production shifted south
to the teeth?
Hmmmm….
That’s when scientists decided to look at
the genome of the modern-day spotted gar to
understand the genetic building blocks of
enamel production.
Researchers already knew that the gar, like
the ancient Psarolepis romeri, produces the
hard enamel-like mineral called ganoine that
covers their scales.
And when they looked at their genome they
found that the gar produces 2 of the 3 proteins
that comprise enamel, further supporting the
evidence that ganoine coated scales are like
the enamel coating of teeth.
This discovery is making scientists rethink
the evolutionary process of how our teeth
became covered in enamel.
Originally, researchers assumed that the enamel-coated
scales of fish shifted and eventually became
teeth, but these new findings suggest that
perhaps the actual body part did not move
from one place to another but that it was
just the enamel production that shifted from
one area of the body to another.
But more research is needed...
So what’s the molar of the story?
We can learn a lot about our evolution from
some unexpected places and that teeth are
some of the coolest parts of our anatomy!
Now you know a little more about teeth...did
you know that teeth can grow in tumors or
cyst?
Check out this video to find out more!
What do you think about this fish tale?
Tell us in the comments below and subscribe
for more DNews.